THIS.
AND WHY WOULD THEY BE?
A CANDIDATE FOR NEW YORK
CITY PUBLIC ADVOCATE.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> HI, TUCKER, HOW ARE YOU
DOING?
>> I'M GREAT.
>> Tucker: I'M A LITTLE BIT
CONFUSED MOST DEBATE ON
CLIMATE CHANGE IT'S REAL AND
THE OTHER WE DON'T HAVE ALL
THE EVIDENCE.
GRANTED I GRANT EVERYTHING
YOU SAY ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE.
>> THANK YOU.
THAT'S A START.
WE ADMIT IT.
>> Tucker: BUT IF YOU REALLY
BELIEVED WHAT YOU ARE SAYING
AND IF BERNIE SANDERS REALLY
BELIEVES WHAT HE IS SAYING,
WHY IS HE FLYING ON PRIVATE
PLANES?
A SINCERE QUESTION?
>> LET'S NOT GET DISTRACTED
FROM THE REAL ISSUE HERE.
>> Tucker: OH, OH, OH.
NO, NO, NO.
I'M NOT GOING TO LET YOU OFF
THAT EASILY.
WHY IS IT NOT A REAL ISSUE
IF CLIMATE CHANGE AS TOLD US
ONLY ISSUE THAT MATTERS WHY
AREN'T WE LIVING LIKE IT'S
THE ONLY ISSUE THAT MATTERS?
>> IT COMES DOWN TO THE
INDUSTRY.
IF THE INDUSTRY WANTS TO
MAKE PLANES THAT EXIST OFF
OF RENEWABLE ENERGY RATHER
THAN OIL AND GAS, THEN, WE
WILL ALL BE ABLE TO LIVE ON
THIS PLANET.
STARTS AT THE INDUSTRY
LEVEL, NOT THE CONSUMER.
IT'S REALLY NOT FAIR TO PUT
THE TAX ON THE INDIVIDUAL.
>> Tucker: IT'S NOT FAIR FOR
SOMEONE WHO IS TELLING US
THE PLANET IS BEING
DESTROYED TO LIVE IN A WAY
THAT SUGGESTS THAT HE
ACTUALLY BELIEVES THE PLANET
IS BEING DESTROYED.
I HONESTLY REALLY DON'T GET
IT.
IF YOU ARE AL GORE AND YOU
SAY NOTHING IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN CLIMATE
CHANGE.
I'M A BETTER PERSON THAN YOU
ARE BECAUSE I CARE MORE THAN
YOU.
BY THE WAY I HAVE ONE OF THE
LARGEST HOUSES IN NASHVILLE
AND PRIVATE AND TAKE A IT
YOU BURR BAN TO THE AIRPORT.
SINCERELY, WHY IS THAT OKAY?
>> INDIVIDUAL CHOICES ARE
NOT GOING TO SOLVE THE
DISASTER THAT WE ARE FACING.
WE ALREADY HAVE A MIGRATION
ISSUE.
WE ALREADY HAVE FLOODING.
WE ALREADY HAVE HURRICANES
THAT HAVE HIT PUERTO RICO,
HAVE HIT NEW ORLEANS, HAVE
HIT FLORIDA AND PLACED SO
MANY WORKING PEOPLE.
INDUSTRY CHANGE.
WE HAVE TO CAP EMISSIONS
GLOBALLY.
IF WE DON'T CAP EMISSIONS
BIG INDUSTRIES AND POLICY
THEN THOSE INDIVIDUAL
CHOICES MEAN NOTHING.
>> Tucker: HOLD ON,
INDIVIDUAL CHOICES ALWAYS
MEAN SOMETHING.
>> IN A LIBERTARIAN FANTASY
WORLD.
>> Tucker: I'M NOT A
LIBERTARIAN AND NOT LIVING
IN A FANTASY WORLD.
IN A REAL LIFE INDIVIDUAL
CHOICES MATTER OR ELSE
WHAT'S THE POINT OF ANY OF
THIS.
LIBERALS USED TO SAY IT
STARTS WITH ONE PERSON.
THEY DON'T ANYMORE BECAUSE
THEY DON'T WANT TO BE HELD
TO THEIR OWN STANDARDS.
THE SOLUTIONS ARE ALWAYS
LIKE ORDINARY WORKING PEOPLE
OUGHT TO PAY HIGHER GAS TAX.
>> NOT THE SOLUTION AT ALL.
WE ARE AGAINST.
THIS PROGRESSIVES AGAINST
THE NEOLIBERALS AND NEOCONS
PROGRESSIVES BELIEVE THIS
NEEDS TO BE A HUGE POLICY
CHANGE.
THE PLACE WHERE WE ARE RIGHT
NOW, IF WE INCREASE THE
TEMPERATURE 1 DEGREE, YOU
AND I WON'T BE LIVING IN
D.C. AND NEW YORK ANYMORE.
WE WILL BE DISPLACED.
AND INDUSTRIES WILL LOSE
MONEY.
>> Tucker: TALK ABOUT THE
POLICY.
SOLUTIONS THAT WILL FLOW
FROM THE PREDICTIONS THAT
YOU ARE MAKING.
IS THERE ANY SOLUTION YOU
HAVE EVER HEARD OF THAT
DOESN'T INCREASE THE PRICE
OF ENERGY?
I HAVE NEVER HEARD OF ONE.
>> IF YOU ARE GOING TO BE
FOCUSED ON THE PRICE OF
ENERGY, WE ARE NOT GOING TO
HAVE A PLANET IN 10 YEARS.
WE HAVE TO TALK ABOUT
CHANGING --
>> Tucker: HOLD ON.
>> LET ME FINISH, TUCKER, LA
LA LA LA LA, WE ARE GOING
DOWN A RABBIT HOLE.
>> Tucker: NO WE'RE NOT.
>> 100 PERCENT RENEWABLE
ENERGY, FORCING THE
COMPANIES THAT ARE JACKING
UP THE PRICES ON WORKING
PEOPLE TO ACTUALLY REDUCE
THEIR EMISSIONS SO THAT
WORKING PEOPLE AREN'T
DISPLACED.
SO WORKING PEOPLE ARE PAY
FOR HURRICANE DAMAGE AND
HAVE CLEAN WATER AND WATER
IS NOT BEING PRIVATIZED.
>> Tucker: VOLUME IS NOT THE
SAME AS AN ARGUMENT.
REALLY SIMPLE QUESTION.
>> YOU DON'T LIKE
OPINIONATED WOMEN, DO YOU?
>> Tucker: I LIVE WITH FOUR
OF THEM.
>> VOLUME.
YOU ARE PRETTY LOUD.
MY EAR PIECE IS BLARING
RIGHT NOW.
>> Tucker: LET ME ASK YOU A
REALLY SIMPLE QUESTION.
WOULD THE SOLUTIONS YOU ARE
ESPOUSING NOW, WOULD THEY
RAISE THE PRICE OF GASOLINE
FOR WAGE EARNERS?
>> NOT WITH THE GREEN NEW
DEAL.
>> Tucker: GAS WOULD BE THE
SAME PRICE.
>> I'M AGAINST RAISING
CONSUMER PRICES.
THAT IS A NEOLIBERAL DESIGN.
I'M A DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST.
I THINK WE SHOULD HAVE
POLICIES AND ACTUALLY MAKE
RICH PEOPLE MILLIONAIRES AND
BILLIONAIRES AND
CORPORATIONS PAY TAXES.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
NO ONE AT THE TOP IS PAYING
TAXES AND THE BURDEN IS
GOING TO THE CONSUMER.
>> Tucker: BUT YOU WOULD
ALLOW PRIVATE PLANES TO FLY,
I GUESS, RIGHT?
>> I THINK PRIVATE PLANES
HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO CHANGE
THEIR STANDARDS.
THAT IS WHAT POLICY IS ALL
ABOUT.
>> Tucker: GET SOLAR PRIVATE
PLANES.
>> I DON'T KNOW HOW THAT
WOULD FUNCTION.
>> Tucker: I DON'T EITHER.
>> OTHER FORMS OF ENERGY.
>> Tucker: NAME ONE.
JUST FOR FUN, NAME A
RENEWABLE ENERGY SOURCE THAT
CAN POWER AN AIRPLANE.
>> WELL, THERE IS -- WE SEE
IT WITH CARS.
>> Tucker: HEMP?
I'M SERIOUS IS THERE ONE?
>> DO YOU KNOW WHAT A PRIUS
IS AND A TESLA IS?
>> Tucker: CAN THEY POWER A
BIG ELECTRIC AIRPLANE?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I'M NO ENGINEER BUT I HAVE
HEARD OF ELECTRIC CARS AND
AIRPLANES AND OTHER FORMS OF
ELECTRIC SOLUTIONS.
THERE IS ALSO SOLAR JENNIFER
RATED SO THAT THE
ELECTRICITY THAT YOU ARE
CHARGING WITH IS SOLAR
ENERGY.
>> Tucker: BACK TO THE
SOLAR.
TEXT ME A PICTURE IF YOU
FIND ONE ON THE INTERNET.